[Music]
good afternoon welcome my name is Jerome
do--she and I'm the belt system lead at
Google hi I'm Leo Samer product manager
and Android team and I'm jvo chakra I'm
a lead for the developer tools ok let's
start with what we worked on last year
so the very first thing that we did was
you know we've been working on namespace
resources German I actually stood here
last year and we talked a lot about
namespace resources and sadly it has not
shipped yet we have gotten a lot of
feedback from you and we're very happy
for that thank you
and as we kept working on it we realized
a couple of things the first one is we
need we needed more features from Gradle
in order to efficiently process areas
that are not namespaced enabled but you
still want to consume in a namespace
module so we've been working with a
greater team very closely over the last
years and we got that down so it's now
available in writer the second thing
that we realized is that studio needed a
lot of work studio has its own
understanding of resources it passes all
your files as you change them it build
its own index and that is used for code
completion resource references for
navigation as well as rendering and so
we needed to update this to be able to
handle both the important m-space
projects and non namespace projects and
then you're all aware of project mobile
you know the last six months we've been
working mostly on quality and not on new
features and so all of that was put on
hold and so as soon as Marvel is done
then we'll keep working on that and
we'll be able to hopefully ship
namespace resources soon in the meantime
we have made some small improvements to
the resource pipeline processing one of
them for example in library resources we
directly generate the our class as class
files rather than Java code that needs
to be compiled in order to reduce the
strain on the Java compilation we have a
few more changes that I've been going in
master very recently you know that we'll
be shipping probably in 3.6 all right
let's talk a little bit about
multi-threading in the envelope again
so for a few years we've encouraged
users to go modular because some modules
can be built in parallel that's true
because all interactions between some
modules have to be done through files so
there's no side effects no side channels
so it's really good
unfortunately that's not true when
you're talking about a single module
right so basically what happens is that
Gradle has to run every single task
sequentially so obviously we've tried to
improve to optimize things by using
executive services and trying to shard
the implementation of some of our tasks
but you know it doesn't really fix the
entire issue and on top of that you know
we have executive services or the
plugins they have other executive
services Caudle demon has its own
executive services so the result is that
we tend to overwhelm the build machines
when we read builds that's really not
good so to solve this problem we've
worked with Gradle on a new API which is
called the workers the workers are
side-effect free because you have to
basically sell you lies all the input
parameters to every work item and it's
going to be dis I realized when the work
item is going to execute so that means
that if you change the parameters after
you do submission the submit II will
never see those changes so there's no no
side-effect
Gradle cannot so much better maintain
the number of threads being used and the
load word the workload so in your sure
that you're not going to theoretically
overwhelm the machine anymore and on top
of that it's relatively easy to retrofit
clusters to use workers so we've been
quite busy at doing this but let's look
and how this impacts to build by using
workers so here we've got a single
module and has three tasks a and you've
got B and C's which depends on a so on
top of these graphics it's what's
happening today when you don't use
workers right so you've got the three
tasks that have to execute sequentially
now when you use a worker like you can
see that the task B is putting a worker
as soon as the worker is being spawned
because there's no side effect possible
any longer Gradle is capable of electing
a new task for execution
so here tax task C can start executing
on a different thread
the worker 4b is completing so obviously
it's very positive because t2 in this
particular case is is much before t1 so
now if you do more and more of this you
can imagine that now there's got to be
more and more threads being used
throughout the build unfortunately you
can end up in a situation which is not
exactly what you wanted in particular
workers are an implementation detail of
your task implementation so basically
that means that there is no decoration
Caudill does not know if your task is
going to be using workers or if it's not
going to be workers so it cannot like in
a select your task just because it seems
it's gonna be faster so in this
particular case it decided to schedule
tasks see before test be nothing
prevents it from doing that and when
that happen well we fall back into where
we started really because the tasks the
executive or because there's no other
possible parallelism that can happen
that as we will have to wait for task C
to be finished and then the workers will
be spooned but at that point there's
nothing less nothing else to be run so
basically you end up exactly the same
situation as you started from so it's
not that great right so to fix this is
basically to switch all of your tasks to
use workers because at that point if you
go back to test B being generated
executive first you can see that the
task C being scheduled as soon as the
worker for that as B starts because you
have a worker C it really does not
impact the overall build time but if
gradall decides that he wants to
schedule tasks C first you can see now
that the task B will complete a lot
earlier than what we've seen before
right so this is very brief description
but basically what is important to
realize is that if you have yourself
tasks that you've wrote if you have
yourself a plug-in you really really
should consider switching all of your
tasks to use workers we have converted
90% of the cutter plug-in tasks to
workers so that means we are ready to
play well with each other and also with
ourselves because we've seen that as we
were switching
some other tasks to workers we actually
accelerated overall real time especially
for projects that have a very few number
of modules or even like a single module
so we can stop thing making things more
and parallel it's on by default in 3.5
so you don't have to do anything except
if you use Kotlin if you use got in any
particularly if you use annotations
processors you need to turn it on
4k apt to be able to to leverage the
feature I suspect it going to be on by
default pretty soon but so far you have
to do it manually okay so one other
thing that we've worked a lot is
artifact transform so artifact transform
a way to process dependencies during
configuration of a project we don't have
access to the dependency graph so we
don't know how many artifacts you know
gonna be consuming because it takes time
to resolve the dependencies and so we
cannot create a per task
dependency task in case we want to
process dependencies to do extract areas
or predicting or things like that
so this is a new API that was introduced
actually a little while back that we've
been using three since trudeau
we work very closely with Gradle again
and we've been using that since 300 in
order to extract air in a more efficient
way than we used to do before
unfortunately the API was not enough for
to enable us to do things like
predicting and disagree and there's a
couple of reasons for that one of them
it did not allow incremental inputs it
did not really super caching and the
other thing is that the scheduling was
not very good we you it used to run as
soon just before the output of the
transform was needed rather than work as
soon as the input of the transform was
ready so in term of critic saying that
new scheduling is going to give us a lot
of benefits so we've been starting to
use that for predicting and assuring and
I'm going to show you a little bit what
that looks like so this is a chrome
trace output john will talk about this
output in a little and what we have here
is a project with about 100 modules
running on a machine with a lot of code
and every little square is basically a
task happening in one of the modules and
so what you can see here without
artifact transform is in order for us to
schedule predicting we cannot have to
wait until all the modules already and
have been built for us to have a task
that consume all of those outputs and
then start doing the predicting and in
fact we do it with the dexing of the
main app and so you can see this task
key or two at the end that's you know
taking a lot of time and also during a
time where we can't do that much
processing because it's very at the end
of the project you know in the app when
all you're done is basically packaging
and Dex merging and do a few things
so with transforms we can schedule that
or greater schedule that for us much
earlier and as soon as a module
generates its jar it can schedule the
predicting library and it can be cached
on its own so you have much more caching
granularity because you don't cache the
whole task that does all the predicting
so just on this module on this project
sorry with hundred modules you can see
that a clean build is improved by 15% by
this introduction another thing that
we've been working on a lot is lazy task
configuration we've been working on for
quite a while but we've basically made
everything lazy but mostly and we wanted
to kind of show you the impact that it
can have so on the left side you have
the same exact module you know hundred
project module and odd module projects
and you can see that if you're running
without a Z task we configure almost
19,000 tasks that's a lot of tasks to
configure and on the right side with the
right flag on we only configure about
3,000 2,400 of which actually needed by
the build and there's a little bit under
800 actually created eagerly this is a
bug that we need to fix in our plugin a
few of them actually needed the some of
them are not and when you look in detail
at the time you can see that
configuration goes from 128 seconds to
about one second but then you also have
some of that time lost back in the
growth calculation right so what's
happening is that as Gradle build a task
graph of all the tasks to execute it
realize that well it needs to configure
those
but overall we have city hanging about
25% configured configuration time on
this project so another thing that we
talked about a lot last year was
incremental and additional processing so
again with Godot we worked on
implementing the ability to have
incremental compilation even when there
is annotation processors on the class
pass this has been delivered so now we
have the ability to run incremental
obviously this is dependent on
annotation processors to play well and
here we have a list of the top ten
annotation processors as we see being
used through our performance data and
we've already converted six of them and
we are still working on the four
remaining ones we will continue
monitoring this list of most use
annotation processors at least open
sourced ones and we will try to convert
them as much as we can but you have to
be careful again that if you have your
own annotation processors it's very
important that you you make the effort
to make it incremental capable usually
it's not very complicated one thing that
we also did as part of this work is to
make sure we blame correctly the
annotation processors which are being
configured and that are not uh not that
are not incremental capable so that if
you are a provider of an annotation
processor you will get started getting
some you know maybe angry emails from
Yui from your users that you know why is
your annotation process you're not
capable of handling incremental
compilation yet so if you see things
which are open source please talk to the
author if you fix which are in-house you
will have to fix it yourself obviously
we also have a page on our documentation
at least all of the annotation processor
that were converted on this list for
some other ones which are not in the top
ten the version at which they started
being incremental capable and we also
list the wunst and the plans that we
have feel free to send us email if you
want us to add some stuff there but it's
basically the reference about what's
available today
and since we are at it we also added
support for Kathleen obviously so now if
you use Kathleen and you have annotation
processors we also have the ability to
run KPT in incremental mode it's
dependent obviously on the same
annotation processors being incremental
but as you can see on those graphs the
numbers are pretty impressive we are
really continuing to push forward the
CRO mentality as being you know a very
important feature of the plugin okay so
one other thing that we did is we try to
improve the performance of sync insights
to do a lot of the time spent when you
import a project is actually spent in
Gradle and so if you look at the old
thing that we had before the first thing
that we need to do is build that model
right we need to query great early in
order to know which module you have what
are the properties and what's the
dependency between module and external
libraries and so we have to call Gretel
which configure their projects because
we need dependencies we resolve the
dependency and then we query that model
the model query is actually very quick
and then well Android relies a lot on
generated source code right your our
class a IDL run the script so we always
call in to another build that configures
again resolve dependency and then run
some tests so we worked closely again
with Gradle in order to contribute some
changes to the tooling a PRF greater in
order to be able to do both in the same
build
so now we can do only one single
configuration we can do one dependency
resolution then we query the model and
during the query of the model we as we
acquire it and we process it inside our
plugin we accumulate the list of tasks
that represent you know generating
sources and then we schedule them and
then Gradle will ruin them after we also
did a change here because studio now is
able to create virtual classes for our
right so as I mentioned earlier studio
is passing your dependency or resource
file as you edit them and it's always
knows what's going on and so it's
creating some virtual our classes so
that it doesn't have to rely on the
build so if you had a string to your
file you don't have to build in order to
update your class it's just don't
virtually for you and so since we do
that we don't have to bill it anymore so
as you sing the post
Singh build which is now integrated just
does not run that task and therefore you
have a faster sink as well so another
thing we launched as you may have heard
is apply changes and this enables you to
make small edits and deploy while
keeping your app in its state there's
actually pretty fast because it does not
restart the app but unlike instant run
which some of you may know it does not
modify the build instead it really finds
the classes on the fly and use some new
runtime instrumentation from the
platform because it depends on this new
runtime instrumentation it's only
available for devices running Android 8
and above it works best when you're
making really small changes inside our
class or making small edit to our
resources but as you may have heard from
tor earlier today this project also
brought a lot of improvement for every
build we'll also looked at the build
output window and try to improve it we
improved the UI and also the underlying
parser to really make sure that all of
your build errors show up as a node in
this window we extract the relevant
information to make sure you have a file
information line pointers the details on
the error and we improved the UI a
little bit to expand the tree scroll and
select the error node automatically
there's a small change but we hope it
make your life easier so as you can see
we've been yeah go for build output
window
so as you can see we've been pretty busy
adding a lot of new stuff to the build
system but I cannot talk about build
without mentioning build speed
so let me deep dive into this a bit
because it's really one of our top
priorities first let me set the stage to
measure build speed internally we use a
set of benchmarks we use some open
source project like Santa tracker mean
SDK 15 and 28 from multi dexing and
another one called tank takeo me and
signal but those are a small ish so we
really wanted to test on large projects
so we generated two project one with
about a hundred module 97 to be precise
and fifty of everything from modules so
15 classes 50 layout etc we also created
an equivalent project of the same size
but all squeezed into one module and
both of the Prados projects have 200
external dependencies and every time we
make a change to the build plug-in R
event those projects on various
scenarios so let me walk you through
some of those one scenario is to make a
code change so we change a little bit of
code and rebuild the project on the open
source project you can see some
improvement ranging from 24 to 36
percent improvement between 3.1 and 3.5
when we looked at the two very large
project and here the legend is large 100
is the one with a hundred module and
large one is the one where everything is
quiz into one module we can see that we
improved by between 50 and 80 percent in
other words here we divided the bill
speed by 2 on the large project with a
lot of modules and by 5 on the single
module 1 the big improvement in 3.4 here
is largely related to the java c
incrementality that was added or that
was improved alright another scenario we
ran is making change to resources
because that happens and so here again
on the open source project we can see
improvement ranging
from 26 to 53 percent and in the large
project we also see good improvements
ranging in the 30 ish percent so those
are two important scenarios editing a
source code or editing resources there's
others that we ran on and we're going to
aggregate the scenarios that I just show
you we saw an average build speed
improvements by 35 percent between 3.1
and 3.5 all right so so far we're happy
but but we also look at real bill speed
that's the one that experienced that's
experienced by all of you and we do this
by aggregating data that all of you or
the one of you that share with us when
you opt into sharing usage statistics
with us and so here shameless plug if
you do not please opt in its aggregated
and it helps us a ton and it's in the
system settings so when we aggregate
those data we see that the median build
speed increased by 25 percent in the
last year ish not though that this is
not really showing the improvement from
3/4 which just when stable a couple
weeks ago as well as 3/5 which just when
beta yesterday so now I show you some
graph going down some graphs going up I
mean starting wondering why well the
reason is that while our benchmark
projects are pretty static your real
projects are growing you're adding line
of code you're adding feeders you're
adding new Gradle plug-in and this grows
impact your build speed so if you're
trying to reconciliate these graphs
going down and up let me walk you
through a real life example looking at
Spotify in the last year and a half the
project grew by 25% when you're looking
at line of code and 234 cents when
looking at modules that's about 3x the
growth in a year and a half it's huge at
the same time cleanbid slowed down by
38% so I'm gonna normalize using line of
code growth and it's still a slow down
by 10% on build not great I've made
this shows some of the current limits
that our pipeline have when we're
dealing with hundreds and hundreds of
modules especially around resource
pipeline but that's something we're
working on and note also here but this
is not showing anything from three four
and three five but the clean bill
doesn't necessarily represents your
day-to-day bills when you build multiple
times a day hopefully a lot of those
bills are incremental and so if you look
again at the Spotify change that's part
if I project the incremental build
actually got faster by 37% and if I
normalize again on the growth from line
of code there's actually two times
faster not too bad actually shows that
making sure everything that can be
incremental actually is is really
important and as I've mentioned when we
add cash ability to the mix it's even
better and so you see here with a lot of
improvement we make to cash ability to
the task the Spotify build cashed this
time improved by 50% while the project
was growing so again to normalize with
the growth of line of code that's about
three times faster if their project have
not grown in the same time so hopefully
all those graphs show you that we are
working very hard to keep improving
build speed and help you get more
productive and the first and best tip to
get your build speed down is to upgrade
to the latest Android Gradle plug-in
version but we know we still have a lot
of work to do mainly around
configuration time resource processing
especially as I mentioned on this
project with lots and lots of modules
and continued improved parallelism
but that's not all we know that many of
you use additional custom Gradle plugin
and we want to help there too so for
that working on a build speed
attribution tool in Android studio the
goal is to help you understand which
plug-in and which tasks are actually
affecting your build speed most and what
you can do about it
because some time you're using a plug-in
that we don't write so we want to help
you tell the plug-in owner if it's you
or someone else what's going wrong and
what what they can do to help and this
will be in Android studio very soon all
right so we're gonna talk about some
tips and some tools about helping you
better configure your project so the
first thing I want to mention is that
you know configuration should really be
fast
I talked to developer lot we you know
with developer who tell me that you know
the configuration is fairly slow
actually talk to the developer just
today telling me hundred and 50 module
almost 10 second configuration and this
is really not in line with what the
baseline should be right so we wanted to
look at how fast should configuration be
so using the same project project that's
about hundred modules you know and and
those modules don't do a lot of
configuration right there's only one
plug-in the android plug-in and it
mostly set up some dependencies and
nothing else so when we look at
configuration using Bill scans we see
that the configuration takes about a
second which you know adds up to about
10 millisecond per module now of course
the task graph computation is there too
but depending on what you're building
you may not do all of it but here for a
large you know for building the whole
app we see about under two second
configuration so if you have 200 modules
you should see four seconds if you're
already seeing 510 seconds and you have
1020 module you Kelly something's
happening right and it's it's actually
hard right now to configure to figure
out exactly what's happening but be
aware that basically every code that you
put in your DSL right because it's code
will at time and there isn't a whole lot
of way to make that faster right the
best way to do it is just you know run a
JVM profiler
and see exactly what's happening you may
be using some plugins that do things
that they shouldn't be doing that are
just slow and of course I mean that
there's a few obvious candidates right
you know don't resolve or dependencies
during configuration don't configure all
the tasks eagerly but really the only
way to do that if you're using
third-party plugin is to profile it
somehow
so in term of speed which you know to
increase your build speed we'll see
still recommend doing several modules
and you know Jerome talked a lot about
workers or you can get pallet them for
worker but you know we also showed that
workers have some limitation right you
know you have to spawn them from your
task and what you're doing that you
can't run any other task and so you're
always going to get better parallelism
from multiple modules so you should
still try to go there in addition to
that you know we see more and more
developers actually using caching
distributed caching or local caching and
so imagine if you have you know a few
local changes and then you rebase your
changes on top of some changes coming
from upstream if you have a single
module well you know if you have some
Java files that have changed you're
going to have to rerun the whole Java
compilation if you have a hundred
modules and you only have a couple maybe
three four or five modules that are
touched all the other modules are good
candidate to actually get the output
directly from the cache so you have
better cache granularity and more likely
to get faster build from that and then
the other aspect of it is compilation
avoidance none of the project we showed
in your benchmark actually use
competition avoidance but it's a very
useful tool so I want to run through a
scenario that explain a little bit to
what competition avoidance is because we
still see some developer not really
understanding what's going on so let's
say you have an app that depends on
library one that depends on library -
that depends on library 3 and so we want
to see the impact of competition
avoidance when library 2 declares its
dependency on library 3 one way or the
other
and so we're going to look at it by
looking at a bunch of tasks compilation
tasks dexing or they're using Java 7 or
Java 8 it's actually has a difference
and then packaging all of that when you
do a code change on library 3 so by
default of course if you do a change on
library 3 library is gonna have to run
it's taxing whether it's Java 7 or Java
8 and it's gonna
and then at the end you're gonna have to
package everything and none of the
library are involved in the packaging so
it's only affecting that particular
module so let's say you do a code
implementation challenge right so you
just go in the library module and you
just change the content of a method
Gradle will do completion avoidance for
you automatically so it will detect that
the API of library 3 did not change and
you will not recompile either library to
library one application it works out of
the box you it doesn't really matter
whether you use API or implementation
for dependencies it just works right
that's kind of like really your
best-case scenario now if you do a
challenge in library 3 that adds a
public method and I'm talking here about
adding it without actually using it and
you've declared library to as an API
library 3 as an api of library 2 then
you're going to recompile everything
alright so you're gonna run compilation
on library to library and an app of
course the output is gonna be the same
so at least in the case of Java 7 you
don't need to run text again right
because Gradle will look at the input of
Dex and will say well it's exactly the
same thing that I had before nothing to
do however for Java 8 that's different
the disagreeing process has to look at
the dependencies so when it process
library 1 it has to go and look at
library 2 and library 3 what their API
is is it using some language feature
that it need to disagree and therefore
it impact the output of library 1 so you
have to redo everything now if you
change the dependency from library to
library using implementation you save a
little bit right basically what you're
doing is you're telling the consumer of
library to that library 3 is hidden from
them so app and library 1 do not see
library 3 at all so automatically you
don't run the Java compilation on them
however right now we still do predicting
in the case of the sugaring that is
actually a problem in a plugin that we
need to fix but once you do that then
you will also not run dexing right which
is important because especially in the
case of Java 8 when you use to Rebecca
language features we have to run it very
often it's extremely hard to try to
reduce the cases where you you're not
doing predicting
we are doing it very often as soon as an
API change and here I'm not necessarily
talking about an API that matters to app
and everyone and library - right you
could have a public class with a public
method that you only use internally in
library 3 and it's still gonna go and
trigger a bunch of changes in your
consuming modules so competition
avoidance is very useful start using it
it's gonna get better as we improve the
plug-in and it's really gonna make your
bill fasters some caveats to
parallelization we see some developer
telling us yeah I have 10 20 modules and
then they say well I have one big app
module with like 90% of my code that's
not helping you should really make you
know as small modules as you can and
then as Leo mentioned earlier our
resource back line is not very efficient
for multi module in fact if you see the
the chart that it shows for research
change for large module with one with
one module and with hundred module the
Huntersville is slower than one module
that's not per area as we start working
on in space again and additional changes
to resource pipeline will get much
better performance in building module
boots alright so how can you understand
your performance I mean we all know that
the unavoidable system is an very open
environment you're not constrained you
can have your own plugins you can have
your own annotation processors you can
write code in the Bill of the huddle so
all these things compound to each other
and eventually it's very difficult for
us to deliver something that we know
we'd go from well because you can
customize it to no end so you need tools
to be able to understand how these
things work and so you've got already a
few tools that are provided by God or
the cuddle scan is one of them it's very
effective it will give you information
about why the tasks run what where the
dependencies all this kind of
information will be given to you one of
the only caveat that it has is that it
forces you to upload some information to
the Velo servers so it's this
information contains things like you
know file paths file names via names and
stuff like that so we understand that
you know not everyone wants to send this
to the external world so therefore there
are some other tools the profiler is
another sim
tool that you can use it will still give
you information about why your tasks run
and all that kind of stuff it's it's not
super visual but it's still interesting
and it's still something you should
consider using but to help you further
we developed an ability to have comm
trace being generated out of your builds
so what we do now is that we are capable
of of generating these and we can
display very visually all the tasks that
are being scheduled per thread so you
can see here on the left-hand side of
the front numbers you can see the tasks
here you've got for instance the tasks
in magenta which is the merge resources
you can even see the workers which are
spawn for that package particular tasks
executing and by the way you can see
here visually that as soon as the task
is done spooning the workers the next
task can start which is the process
application manifest in green so you can
see how here very visually how then your
tasks can can be running in parallel
even within a single module because here
there's only one module on blue here
we've got threads
these are threads which are just you
know used using the executive services
so this gives you a very good visual
again about how we use the jvm resources
you can even go a little deeper
for instance here you can see that the
task execution span is this magenta
color you can see that there is the
up-to-date check such the time that God
will spend to figure out the funds which
are out to date then you've got the task
implementation which is the old phases
so that's really the code of the task
itself and then we even further down
we've we kind of like you know split it
up and further to get the different
phases so that gives us a lot of
information about how those tasks are
implemented so this is for our tasks
obviously if you were to run this chrome
trace with a different plugin or with
your own tasks you will see your tasks
as well but it would not be as
descriptive as this nevertheless would
be still very interesting visually to
figure out where those tasks belong and
so on so now if you face yourself with
you know the impression that your build
is slow which I'm sure is 99% of you
we would really recommend that if you
want to file a bug or tell us that you
know the build is slow and it should be
improved that you provide us at the very
least this contrast so that we can
visually look into what's going on there
is no PII information we don't have fine
names we don't have task name we know
that variant names there's nothing in
there that should be of any concern this
is the same data that we use that's the
data that we upload to our server so if
you opted in the server that we do to
the data that Leo used to do all these
graphs earlier you don't share anything
else so to have the trace enabled you
just need to add this property and then
you will find a JSON file inside the
build on the weight profile that JSON
file you can use it in Chrome you can
load the chrome tracing facility in
chrome and then you can load that file
and then you will see exactly what I
just displayed in the previous slides
again it is super visual very useful it
taught us a few things when we started
looking at this even ourselves so I
totally recommend that if you have a
very sophisticated build you try this
because you might get some few surprises
around there and with that I'd like to
thank you for coming today
[Music]